so that because of that crash production
yeah hey everyone what's happening it's
my you go today I'm joined here by Joel
ah what up I'm Joel how you guys doing
so today I want to answer a lot of
questions that you've had about
internships everything from how to get
one and what to expect during one and
everything in between
between us we've had a lot of
internships with all of our collective
and combined experiences hopefully what
we're going to talk about today is
helpful for you also Drummey do you want
to introduce yourself and talk about
what you do later I guess you know I'm
also a content creator I go by the name
Jonah my actual name is Jonathon mom and
I've been working in tech for a while
now so yeah hopefully we can shed some
light on that so first we want to answer
the question why even do an internship
well first of all they're really
important in terms of like personal
development skills development and all
that but for me especially I think it
was really important in terms of you
know meeting new people meeting new
friends and I actually met some of my
best friends through internships it is
really fun hanging out with like people
who kind of have some like career goals
as you and to be able to like make
something together is really fun why I
think internships are really important
is because there's a lot of skills that
you learn for software engineering in
school studying computer science but
there's a lot of hands-on skills that
you also have to develop in order to
become a good software engineer so
things like how to work in a team how
does the software development process
and cycle work what's scrum and agile
and all those things are really
important and will help you kind of hit
the ground running right after you
graduate from college and so learning
those things during an internship is
really great and you get a head start on
yeah that's for sure
very true like I didn't know what good
was until I started my internships like
because especially for my program it's
like computer science program it's not a
lot of software engineering the more
like theoretical computer science right
so I never actually learned how to like
build stuff I only learned like
algorithms that we never use at all yeah
you know so with these internships I
found use like how to build stuff
you know just simple things like no jazz
apps and stuff like that and yeah it
helps me like have a lot more fun
encoding yeah it does really get to like
know and understand what you learn in
school actually translates to like stuff
that you build that helps people at
least that's what I'm like really really
passionate about and seeing that kind of
like come to fruition and seeing real
people use the software you make is so
rewarding you know so let's jump into a
little bit about our background so we've
kind of set some context and so we can
talk about like we went to school and
kind of what was the atmosphere and
attitude toward internships at our
respective schools yes so for me I went
to University of Waterloo are suppose a
little bit different because we have to
do five to six internships within your
whole education - yeah so that's a lot
so for us you know internships are what
we call them coops and their big part of
our careers so we love internships our
school is known for internships because
we just do so many but I yeah so that's
kind of like our school so I went to UC
San Diego as referenced in my other
video if you haven't checked that out
I'll leave the link in the description
box below the computer science program
was really big and it was kind of the
typical for your CS program basically
and what we didn't have requirements on
having to do internships in order to
graduate like your school did a lot of
people did internships at least once
throughout their four years most
commonly right after their third year
which is the year right before they tend
to graduate
we had job fairs on campus that helped
students get these internships as well
as get full-time jobs after they
graduate so there's a lot of big
companies like Google Facebook Apple as
well as more mid-sized companies to that
we're looking to hire
soon oh so German can you tell me about
what internships would have done and
what companies were act yeah sure so I
started my first internship at Citadel
which is kind of like a hedge fund
company as a software engineer and then
I did LinkedIn as a software engineer
and then I did Facebook as a data
scientist and then Microsoft as a
program manager yeah a lot of different
things yeah a lot of soul-searching
[Laughter]
so now we're gonna dive into how to get
an internship so German what's your the
best piece of advice on how to get an
internship yeah so I I guess for me how
I think about it there's two phases the
first phase is getting the interview and
then the second phase is kicking ass in
the interview the first phase for me is
you just gotta get recognized by the
recruiters so either by you know having
a really good resume or getting a
referral I guess and then the second
part is more about acing the interview
and I suggest to just brush up on your
coding interview skills and there's a
good book on cracking the coding
interview I'm sure you guys talked about
I think one thing that was really
helpful for me was making friends with
people who are older than me and kind of
expanding my network as they start
working full-time jobs or their
companies they're going to usually be
part of the recruiting efforts at their
school to hire students so generally
what are some things that you did to
help you get these internships my
story's a little bit different I
actually want to be investment back oh
yeah I don't want to be a star in
general and then I did like trading
competitions I started also learning
Python I was really interested in
finance and it was a website called in
trade comm where you could you know
trade about events like for example
while I'm gonna win the election or not
and then what I did was I made a bot
that kind of like values those like
events in an engineering point of view
it was you know pretty cool because I
made a Python bond and it worked
decently you know and yeah I think
that's how I got the attention of civil
my first internship I guess for me as I
spend in my other video my first
internship I got by first working there
is kind of like an administrative
assistant and doing that kind of like
foot-in-the-door thing where I would be
not working as a software engineering
intern but I was working as someone else
as like a different role
soon after working that role people knew
who I was and like my work ethic and all
that kind of stuff so when I went to
apply for the internship there Eddie
knew who I was and so they were like
cool yeah like you have a spot in the
internship program yeah I guess that's
in there proof of like how networking is
pretty important yeah and I know some
people do hackathons
some companies sponsor these hackathons
and sometimes give out interviews your
offer is to kind of like the wing team
so that's one way
I remember professors of my university
had connections with companies and
recruiters and so he would be able to
like pick his like top students maybe
not necessarily by grade but the ones
that he had a connection with and the
ones that he really liked and so yeah
there's a lot of other ways to kind of
like get noticed other than just like
making a good resume instead yeah one
thing to know is that most companies
tend to look for interns who are in
their third year because they want to be
able to hire that person full-time after
they graduate and so it's kind of more
rare to find internships for a first and
second year students but it's also very
possible to do so it's just you have to
find other ways of getting there because
you think yeah definitely don't feel
like oh I'm not qualified because of
that or because oh they rejected me I'm
probably not qualified sometimes you are
qualified but it's just too early
because they actually want to turn you
into a full time right away my friend he
had a team where they were competing on
a Facebook hackathon because Facebook
used to do used to host hackathons
around schools and he had this app that
allows you to turn your phone into a
mousepad so you could control your
computer using your phone and they want
first place and because of that all of
them got an interview for Facebook and
then the AC interview and then he worked
for Facebook as a freshman so just
because you're a freshman doesn't mean
that can't aim for like the top
companies so now let's dive into kind of
what you need to know before starting an
internship and here we want to highlight
what are things that you should expect
just some more information about the
internship itself yeah sure so I
remember when I just got my first
internship yeah she's a pretty excited
you know your boss but then wow you know
you're almost to the actual day of the
internship you like oh my god can I do
it is like a little bit scary I just
want to tell you don't be afraid you
know it's normal that you're afraid but
you don't need to be because a lot of
the things that you don't know you will
learn you know they don't expect you to
be you know as productive as a full-time
employee you're an intern
you're here to learn and are here to
help you learn yeah I I felt that every
single time before any of my internships
I was like if I qualified for this like
are you sure you want me the imposter
syndrome settled it's so hard my head
like why do they want me but yeah once
you start it's like there you have the
program set up for you typically so that
you can succeed in such a way that
you're learning throughout the whole
thing you are there to learn and so ask
lots and lots of questions right even
things that you think are stupid
questions when you ask them the whole
point I think give an internship is to
really just absorb a lot of information
and just like every bit of it too so
there's an acronym you don't know ask
what it is even if everyone else is
doing around maybe know it like it
that's okay to learn so one question
that I get frequently is do you even
know anything before an internship
things like programming language and
like texts as Jim woody um I appreciate
don't think so me because I've been
working for bigger companies but big
companies don't expect you to be an
expert on and anguish I didn't know how
to like write C++ code and then they
just expect you that you'll learn on the
job so for me I didn't need to like for
example what happened at Citadel was I
joined a team do you know C++ I'm like
no and then it's okay don't worry and it
just gave me a whole C++ book and then I
started coding so yeah yeah they don't
expect you to like be a pro at
JavaScript even just like have they
don't expect you to have even written
JavaScript before they have a whole
codebase that shows you how to write
JavaScript and there's software
engineers who's been writing JavaScript
for a long time that are going to show
you how to learn those things and so
that's not like a requirement at all I
think what's more important is that you
show that you're willing to learn and
that you know that you don't understand
everything that's that's really ok so
let's talk about after the internship so
Jonah after all of your internship
experiences do you think that they
helped you to decide what you want it to
do and you didn't want to do yeah
definitely like especially because I try
like almost everything like sovereign
debt size NPM it really helped me
understand what I really wanted to do
and when I did software like I realized
like oh I really building things but for
example when I fit data size I
understood like oh I really like
analyzing data and then PN is more like
I like you know thinking about the
product and then
so that helped me understand that oh I
think I did it like Davis Lance Moore
and I like p.m. a little bit more in
software engineering so that helped me
kind of like choose my career do you
think that if you hadn't done this
internship but maybe you like studied
those concepts in school would you have
had kind of the same sort of learnings
oh yeah definitely not because you know
the stats classes in schools are really
basic and not applied at all so I would
never want to be a data scientist if you
know if I just learned it from school
yeah Facebook really helped me
understand like you know the impact that
you can have using data awesome so we
talked a lot about internships today and
I want to thank you for being on my
channel thank you for having me um where
can't everyone find you yeah sure so you
could definitely check me a coma I'm a
very new trader I only have like one
video now which is kind of like a
mockumentary of me starting a startup
and yeah like I'll be talking a lot
about tech and hopefully I can merge
tech and entertainment into what it is
my channel go check out his stuff and
you can always find me on Twitter and
Instagram as hello and when you go don't
forget to Like and subscribe if you like
this video and we will see you next time
see ya
[Music]